[Musique]
nicolas bay invités d'auditions
publiques dans le cadre de la campagne
pour les élections européennes bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes candidat
bien sûr vous même un nouveau mandat
puisque vous siégez déjà à strasbourg et
à bruxelles merci donc d'être avec nous
avec les chaînes parlementaires avec le
figaro et avec la fp d'emblée gym
jarrassé et paul briat sont avec moi
messieurs bonsoir de saveur au riad
mancini et brigitte boucher comme chaque
semaine et puis deux parlementaires
nicolas bay viendront vous interpeller
deux parlementaires nationaux le député
en marche ludovic mendes et le sénateur
et l'air jérôme baschet les internautes
et le chat du figaro bien sûr sont
ouverts pour vous les internautes
vous pouvez réagir à l'émission
interpeller notre invité je me ferais
votre relais donc dit que l'abbé
emmanuel macron est annoncée à
l'offensive dans cette campagne oui
particulièrement en ce jour d'ailleurs
ou même sait s'il s'agit là de son
premier ministre edouard philippe eelv
on dit qu'il va enchaîner les meetings
peut-être deux par semaine a jusqu'au
jour du scrutin
en tous les cas ce soir il est à caen
avec bien sûr la tête de liste nathalie
l'oiseau qui a fait un détour tout à
l'heure par le mémorial de la seconde
guerre mondiale je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez cet endroit quelques langues
j'ai visité et revisité avec marine le
pen pendant la campagne des élections
européennes précédentes c'est en 2014
et bien tout à l'heure un atelier
l'oiseau vous attaquez vous le
rassemblement national en citant
françois mitterrand le nationalisme
c'est la guerre
c'est vraiment original elle en est à
exhumer les vieilles citation de
françois mitterrand pour essayer de se
donner une posture face au rassemblement
national on voit que nathalie loiseau sa
candidature est un peu en difficulté
certains diront même en perdition qu'est
ce que vous dites vous je crois que la
réalité c'est que nathalie l'oiseau
personne ne la connaissait avant qu'elle
soit la tête de liste de la république
en marche et aujourd'hui on voit qu'elle
elle défend un projet qui je croyais pas
du tout susceptible de rassurer ni de
rassembler les français et on voit que
cette campagne de la république en
marche n'existait pas jusqu'à maintenant
alors on nous annonce de manière
tonitruante au président de la
république le premier ministre
on passe un peu d'un excès à l'autre
emmanuel macron depuis des mois il a
tout fait pour que la campagne
européenne n'ait pas lieu
nous on est en campagne depuis longtemps
ça fait depuis le mois de janvier lui
avec le grand débat qui était en fait un
grand monologue avec la restitution du
grand débat et le séquençage des
annonces il a tout fait pour occulter
totalement ce débat des européennes
parce qu'il est sans doute un peu il
craint un peu le verdict des urnes
aujourd'hui changement de pied total
qu'à peine trois semaines avant le
scrutin
il va essayer de mettre tous les moyens
de l'état les ministres en première
ligne pour sauver le soldat loiseau tout
ça donne un sentiment de fébrilité
j'aime
en effet vous l'avez dit edouard
philippe sera ce soir à caen meeting
comment justement vous analysez
cette participation du premier c'est
habituellement pour un prémice de
participer à une campagne électorale
finalement il sait pas en soi ni
interdite ni contestable
après tout il a bien le droit mais ça
veut dire que la campagne comment on
peut pas à la fois nous avons approché à
nous de faire de cette de ce scrutin des
européennes aussi un enjeu national et
ça l'est indéniablement c'est la
première élection depuis le début du
quinquennat
c'est la seule élection à dimension
nationale avant le cycle des élections
locales qui a lieu pendant le
quinquennat donc c'est normal que les
français s'en saisissent aussi pour dire
ce qu'il pense de la politique nationale
mais les ouvriers vous réjouir
finalement que la campagne commence pour
donner la saison je disais vous
attendiez ça c'est parti il était temps
nous ça nous dérange pas du tout et on a
beaucoup de choses à dire sur la tête
haute
enfin consiste à taper sur macro ou non
ses objectifs prioritaires
peut-être même le sol c'est affaiblir le
chef de l'état jusqu'à maintenant on n'a
pas eu tellement besoin de l'affaiblir
il s'est fait lui tout seul il fait il
s'est affaibli aussi par le objets qui
suscite chez les français nous on a fait
toute la campagne depuis trois mois sur
notre projet européen en expliquant
notre projet l'architecturé
institutionnelle qu'on veut pour pour
l'europe des nations et des protections
chardonnay le changement d'orientation
politique mais c'est vrai que en faisant
ce grand débat dans tout le monde s'est
largement moqué les français s'ils s'en
sont pas s'ils sont pas intéressés ce
grand débat est bien et même après a
effectivement de fête cristallisé
d'autant plus qu'au stylet français par
dell a appelé à un acte du 26 du 26 mai
contre emmanuel macron ça c'est quand
même une référendum anti makongo mais
c'est évidemment l'enjeu
emmanuel macron défend un projet
européen aller toujours plus loin dans
le fédéralisme européen c'est à dire
dans cette union européenne qui n'a pas
marché
nous nous portons un projet qui est
exactement le contraire donc bien sûr
que mma qu'on représente avec la liste
conduite par nathalie l'oiseau ce projet
de l'union européenne tels que les
français n'en veulent plus voilà c'est
paulo bre york que se passera-t-il
nicolas décide aventures de lanciné la
liste du racing balade du rassemblement
national arrive
qu'est-ce que ça va changer lille à cinq
ans en 2014 vous êtes arrivés en tête
l'union européenne a continué etc
qu'est-ce qu'on quoi ce serait différent
si une grosse différence parce qu'en
souvenez vous de la campagne la question
qui se posait pour l'après élection
c'était est-ce qu'on arrivera constituer
un groupe au parlement européen et de
fait c'est une bonne question puisque
pendant un an nous n'y sommes pas
parvenus on a finalement construit un
gros aujourd'hui c'est un groupe que je
copréside au parlement européen on a une
quarantaine de dépouilles de huit
nationalités différentes
aujourd'hui la question qui se pose elle
est plus celle là parce que là le
paysage politique européen a changé
emmanuel macron et isolés sur la scène
européenne
nos alliés sont arrivés au pouvoir en
italie en autriche
nos idées sont au pouvoir en hongrie en
pologne
nous avons des alliés qui sont des
forces politiques incontournables qui
vont accéder aux responsabilités dans
les mois les années qui viennent et nous
pouvons demain constituer un groupe qui
sera l'une des principales composantes
du parlement opère donc quand on dit
qu'on veut tout changer du sol au
plafond
changer le fonctionnement changer les
orientations de l'union européenne
ça devient possible l'europe des nations
c'est pas simplement un slogan
aujourd'hui en 2019 en 2014 peut-être
mais en 2019 c'est une réalité concrète
qui est en train de prendre forme
regardez sur les questions migratoires
regardez sur les protections économique
regardez sur la nécessité d'en finir
avec les pouvoirs exorbitants de la
commission européenne et bien cette
cette vision là la vision plus important
elle est partagée par tous à l'échelle
continentale
emmanuel macron sur la scène européenne
avec angela merkel qui en préretraite et
jean claude juncker qui en fin de course
et bien il est finalement très isolée
pour pas dire marginalisés natale et
l'oiseau
vous dis non si vous votez rassemblement
national le 26 mai vous votez pour la
destruction de l'union européenne et
pour un affaiblissement de l'influencé
française et vous avez une espèce de
fable
c'est bien pour les enfants mais je
pense pas que ça marche avec des
électeurs raisonnable qui consiste à
dire pour madame loiseau alors il y
aurait d'un côté les gentils
progressiste européiste et de l'autre
côté les méchants nationaliste qui
veulent donner à l'europe
c'est eux qui ont détruit l'europe c'est
eux qui ont construit une machine
technocratique qui affaiblit
collectivement nos nations lainesse et
les grandes nations d'europe je pense
aux plus peuplé l'espagne l'italie la
grande bretagne la france ont davantage
rayonner à travers le monde
lorsqu'elle n'était pas dans cette union
européenne qui est devenu un carcan que
depuis qu'elle y sont et puis moi je
retourne l'argument même loiseau quel
est son bilan à elle parce que c'est
bien gentil d'attaquer le rassemblement
national en faisant croire que parce
qu'on arrive beaucoup de députés en 2014
on sera les sortants non on est
minoritaire et on a face à nous un bloc
majoritaire constitué des amis de man
l'oiseau de monsieur bellamy et des
socialistes ça c'est la réalité
mais madame l'oiseau ça fait deux ans
qu'elle est ministre des affaires
européennes
quel a été son bilan partie 2 en
obligeant à vous mais non le mandat sur
l'alimentaire au parlement européen si
vous deviez citer par exemple une mesure
concrète pour laquelle vous avez ouvrait
à strasbourg et kehl énormément de deux
dossiers sur lesquels on a travaillé et
sur lesquels on a obtenu de bons
résultats je pense par exemple à la
diact us le droit d'auteur on a voté
pour
nos députés qui travaillent dans ce
domaine là où influait sur un certain
nombre de modifications de ce texte dont
on a on a travaillé à l'intérêt général
on a voté vous savez contrairement à ce
qu'il dit parfois bêtement par nos
adversaires qui ne connaissent rien un
sujet européen énormément de textes qui
nous semblaient aller dans le sens de
l'intérêt général et on l'a fait
d'ailleurs au parlement européen sans
sectarisme c'est à dire qu'on regarde
pas quand un amendement nous semble
aller dans le bon sens il vient de la
droite de la gauche ou de l'extrême
gauche ou le vote alors que c'est le
contraire
eux ils sont d'accord avec un texte
qu'on va présenter mais simplement parce
que c'est le rassemblement national où
le groupe europe des nations et du latin
qu'il présente et bien ils vont voter
contre et c'est cette manière de faire
la politique
elle est finalement assez détestable et
je pense assez rejetée par nos
concitoyens que
nous annoncer que vous êtes prêts à des
majorités par exemple d'idées avec la
gauche radicale par exemple la gauche
mélenchonistes qui réclame comme vous
une révision des traités
notre action de cette emphase toute
notre action depuis cinq ans au
parlement européen a montré qu'on était
capable de participer sur un certain
nombre de votes qui nous semble aller
dans le bon sens à des majorités qui
sont très variées d'ailleurs qui peuvent
être aussi bien avec la droite que la
gauche
oui vous savez il faut pas mais parce
que vous avez cités l'air vous avez coup
de citer le ps c'était à télé loisirs
mais aussi des mouvements mélenchon ni
le ciel est bleu ciel est bleu
je vais pas dire le contraire évidemment
qu'on peut être d'accord sur un stand de
sujets ça arrive et c'est normal et je
dirais même c'est rassurant le ce serait
inquiétant si par principe on était dans
l'opposition systématique on a des
désaccords de fond complet mélenchon les
pour une fiscalité confiscatoire il est
pour la régularisation totale des
clandestins et pour l'accueil de
l'immigration on est en désaccord ou
voilà mais on peut très bien avoir sur
tel ou tel sujet par exemple une
négociation des traités européens
on peut avoir des accords par exemple
sur les traités de libre échange et je
moi je reconnais je prends ce qu'est une
incohérence politique dans l'attitude de
mélenchon mais je reconnais qu'il a ils
ont mené aussi le combat contre ces
traités de libre échange qui ont
finalement été votées par les maquereaux
nice par les républicains au parlement
repères mais donc bien sûr qu'on peut au
moins sur le constat pas toujours ces
propositions mais au moins c'est le
constat avant des points de convergence
pour autant le garder
on avait vu une évolution de la ligne du
parti duras nationale où finalement vous
accommoder deux roues et on voyait bien
aussi de l'union européenne et puis
soudainement il ya eu une espèce de
radicalisation c'est en tout cas certain
qu'ils vont analyser ainsi marine le pen
a parlé de du 1er ssl a parlé d'un
tchernobyl économique social et
humanitaire démographique
à propos de l'union européenne et puis
elle reprend aussi à son compte une
théorie fumeuse second certains selon
laquelle l'union européenne et n'est
finalement qu'un plan élaboré à
washington
la guerre par des financiers américains
c'est le livre de cellules de films de
vie dont elle épouse les thèses cette
qualité on ignorait ce qu'il est ce qu
est ce que la vigne du rassemblement
salle a évolué sur notre vision est très
clair on veut tout changer changer
totalement aussi bien le fonctionnement
que les orientations de l'union
européenne notamment sur les pères
fondateurs comme on les appelle -
schumann tout le monde sait bien qu'il y
avait des liens très étroits qu'ils
assumaient des états unis le fait de
dire ça c'est en soi assez anodin et
dans une campagne ça ne sont pas bien
sûr que l'union européenne s'est nommé
rss aujourd'hui écouter aujourd'hui vous
avez la commission européenne qui
détient tous les pouvoirs des
commissions européen que personne n'a
élus et que personne ne connaît qui
aujourd'hui ont l'exclusivité de
l'initiative législative ou ensuite la
réglementation ensuite sa transposition
dans le droit national des textes
européens sont même garant des traités
donc peuvent faire de l'ingérence dans
les états membres sur tous les sujets
qui ne sont pas de la compétence de
l'union européenne on peut pas accepter
ça le l'union aujourd'hui les
commissaires européens tablent sur les
doigts de la hongrie parce qu'elle
refusait côté de migrants l'union
européenne a négocié avec theresa may un
texte qui aboutit en pratique à
maintenir le royaume uni dans tous les
dispositifs de l'union européenne
jusqu'en 2022 et même à continuer de
payer autant qu'aujourd'hui c'était à 5
milliards par an alors que les
britanniques il ya maintenant trois ans
on votait pour sortir donc il ya un
problème de fonctionnement
il n'est pas démocratique il est au pas
bougé tout est à changer tout est à
acheter mais vous qu'en avez vous
finalement qui a changé vous avez changé
ou vous même puisque vous voulez garder
l'euro par exemple vous restez dans
l'union et vous savez sur septembre en
même temps vous parlez de tchernobyl sur
cette question monétaire on a une
approche très pragmatique on n'est pas
des vampires changé on est pas des
idéologues
on a posé la question monétaire elle
épate avoue aujourd'hui on a une monnaie
unique européenne qui sert
principalement les intérêts de
l'allemagne des anciens pays de la zone
marquée également au détriment de la
plupart des autres la bce est installé à
francfort ce n'est pas un hasard
et évidemment la politique qui consiste
uniquement à lutter contre l'inflation a
pour effet d'avoir une monnaie très
fortement évalué trop forte pour la
plupart des pays de la zone
donc on aurait avec nounous avec 60
milliards de déficit de balance
commerciale un terrain voit une monnaie
plus faible ça lancera des exportations
sec à oxygène ray notre économie dia ça
ce n'est pas scandaleux c'est normal la
monnaie doit être
outils qui servent l'économie c'est pas
le cas ou pas suffisamment le cas
aujourd'hui
voilà donc il faut plus que la bce soit
indépendante c'est ça que je pense qu'il
faut une gouvernance politique et alors
comment on fait pour une gouvernance et
une et on se met à la tête des locaux
chacun a ses intérêts économiques
nationaux a fait quand vous regardez la
fonction des exportations des
importations les la monnaie c'est ça ce
ça se gère pas c'est vrai c'est pas
simple mais comme il faut se mettre
autour de la table renégocier l'accord
les textes modifier le fonctionnement la
zone euro honnêtement aujourd'hui sans
doute une quinzaine de pays sur 19 qui
aurait plutôt intérêt à ce que l'euro
soit un niveau plus faible
bon on voulait donc on peut très bien
aboutir à sa part une négociation il
s'agit pas de renverser la table
il s'agit pas de deux comme on dit à
d'affaiblir notre économie c'est
exactement le contraire il s'agit de
retrouver une monnaie qui soit un outil
et qui servent l'économie française
voilà c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui très
critique sur le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne l'un de vos anciens
amis peut-être qu'il est toujours votre
ami florian philippot est monté à vous
avez vu sur le bâtiment de la trésorerie
de forbach l'autre jour et il a commis
ce geste il a jeté par terre
le drapeau étoilé de l'union européenne
est ce que vous avez été choqué moi je
trouve cela dérisoire outrancier et
surtout je pense que ça correspond à
quelqu'un qui s'enferme dans une
marginalité électorale désormais il y a
été de ceux qui dans nos rangs plaidait
pour une ligne extrêmement brutale de
sortie unilatérale de l'union européenne
nous nous avons toujours une approche
raisonnable à négocier les traités
européens
faire en sorte que le fonctionnement de
l'europe se fasse avec les nations et
les peuples et non plus entre les mains
des commissaires
voilà c'est une différence total de
points de vue on voit que lui les voilà
il cherche
il est dans la logique de la rupture et
je pense qu'il est voilà il est
aujourd'hui à 1 ou 2 % dans les sondages
il essaie de faire parler de lui par
tous les moyens voilà le journal
l'opinion nous apprend ce soir que
florian philippot aurait proposé un deal
avec un nicolas dupont aignan pour une
alliance aux européennes est ce que ça
vous semble crédible
en tout cas il m'a pas mis dans la
confidence donc vous pose à la gloire à
nicolas dupont aignan écoutez on a pu on
a eu l'occasion de se croiser on peut se
saluer mais il a souhaité comme on dit à
constituer une liste on lui a tendu la
main on a proposé une liste commune il a
pas fait faire une liste a pas bon
aujourd'hui il est il oscille entre 3 et
5% dans les sondages
on voit bien que cette démarche un peu
jusqu'au boutiste et un peu solitaire ne
mène pas grand chose je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le rassemblement national
a montré sa capacité à élargir à
rassembler on a sur notre liste thierry
mariani qui est un ancien ministre
on l'a jean paul garraud 4 c'était l'été
pour cent qui vous manquent peut-être
pour tuer le match avec nathalie loiseau
a je pense qu'on peut parfaitement
arrivé en tête le 26 mai même s'il ya
des petites listes qui font 1 2 3% à
côté c'est pas grave je vais vous n'êtes
pas sûr d'arriver en tête la non moi je
ne serai pas suis pas madame soleil
1 je pense que les conditions sont
réunies je pense que la défiance à
l'égard des manuels macron cumulé au
fait qu' aucune dynamique en faveur de
nathalie oiseaux peut nous permettre
d'arriver en d'arrivée en tête
et peut-être même largement en tête le
26 mai mais il faut pour cela que les
électeurs se mobilisent qu'ils prennent
conscience de l'importance d'aller voter
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de français
qui aujourd'hui se désintéresse un peu
écoeurés par la politique
ils ont essayé la droite ils ont été
déçus c est la gauche ils ont été
également ils se sentent aujourd'hui
trahis par macron et certains ont
tendance à se détourner des urnes parce
que je leur dis c'est qu'il faut aller
voter il faut pas aller si jamais ils
vont pas voter ils laisseront le pouvoir
à ceux qui à ceux qui sont déjà
installés et sa aggravera les politiques
menées dans les français souffrent de la
montée nyon qui a plusieurs figures des
gilets jaunes sur sa liste c'est aussi
le cas de philippe haut c'est aussi le
cas de la france insoumise et puis vous
même mais rennes vous vous êtes
revendiqué une partie des jurys jaune or
on a appris qu'il y avait au moins trois
listes de jets régionaux en plus qui
seront candidates
est-ce qu'on n'est pas finalement
échouer à capter cette colère des gilets
jaunes qui manifestement est disséminée
à travers de nombreuses vies vous l'avez
vu depuis le début de ce mouvement nous
on a respecté le caractère non partisan
citoyens et on n'a pas cherché à faire
de la récupération contrairement par
exemple à mélenchon qui essayaient à
tout prix d'occuper un mouvement dont
l'adn est un anti fiscaliste mélenchon
qui voulaient 50 milliards d'euros
d'impôts supplémentaires dans son
programme de 2007 il n'était pas le plus
crédible
bah vous à nous on a apporté une réponse
la réponse démocratique le f ardennes
initiative citoyenne on a toujours
défendu depuis des décennies la réponse
sur la fracture territoriale en finir
avec la logique qui consiste à mettre
tout l'argent dans les grandes villes
avec les campagnes françaises qui
meurent ou les services publics
disparaître et ayant et aussi résoudre
la fracture sur le pouvoir d'achat qui
est très profonde on a 48 % de notre pib
en mobylette war c'est devenu
insoutenable il faut baisser massivement
les impôts vous avez vous dit
on a fait la liste gilet jaune créé des
monts apporte une réponse politique aux
revendications légitimement écrit par
les gilet jaune et honnêtement vous avez
cité deux ou trois listes qui sont
donnés tout un ou deux pourcent
ça montre bien que ce ne sont pas les
gilet jaune mais des gilet jaune c'est
financ elle que individualités qui ont
pris des initiatives qui veulent se
présenter c'est très respectable tous
les citoyens ont droit de se présenter
mais je pense que l'immense majorité de
ceux qui se sont mobilisés
dayal et gilet jaune et bien c'est nous
qui sommes les plus à même d'apporter
une réponse politique globale pas
simplement la protestation mais une
vraie réponse pour plus de démocratie
pour plus de pouvoir d'achat et pour que
les campagnes abandonné les la ruralité
française soit pas continue pas être
comme sa méprise et emmanuel macron lors
de sa conférence de presse est venue sur
la question des frontières un peu sur
votre terre il a dit que la france était
une maison dans laquelle on ne pouvait
pas rentrer comme ça est ce que vous
pensez qu'il peut peut-être assécher une
partie de votre électorat comme il l'a
fait avec l'électorat de la droite
classique
non je pense qu'il va rien à sécher du
tout parce qu'il incarne aujourd'hui le
laxisme migratoires mais elle m'a grand
jamais il va soir il a changé de pied
non mais la basse cour il suffit pas de
discours quand on est président de la
république c'est sur les actes qu'on
doit répondre pas sur les discours
aujourd'hui en france il ya 450 mille
personnes qui entrent chaque année 250
5000 au titre de l'immigration légale en
titre de séjour
jamais on n'a atteint un niveau aussi
élevé 1 sous les précédents mandats
mandature ensuite vous avez cent vingt
mille demandeurs d'asile dont l'immense
majorité ne sont pas éligibles au droit
d'asile mais ne sont pas des buttes et
lorsqu'il lorsqu'il la demande d'asile a
fusé vous avez 50 mille mineurs isolés
dont tout le monde sait qu'un parti qui
sont pas des mineurs et vous avez des
dizaines de milliers de clandestins
aussi bien qu'ils arrivent en est trop
pauvre en outre-mer on a hâte
on atteint un niveau dramatique une
immigration qui est massive totalement
incontrôlée et le fait qu emmanuel
macron 10 on les accueille ont traité
demande d'asile sur le sol français
il est un des rares en europe a dit
ranque a tenu encore ce discours
totalement irresponsable il la fermeté
c'est protéger nos frontières et faire
en sorte que les demandes d'asile
interviennent dans les pays tiers allez
cette question sans doute qu on
l'abordera à nouveau dans le courant
cette émission merci messieurs c'est la
séquence des parlementaires maintenant
comme je voulais annoncé
voilà nicolas bay nous accueillons le
député en marche de la moselle ludovic
madec bonsoir merci d'être là à vos
côtés le sénateur et l'air de l'oise
jérôme bascher messieurs bonsoir bonsoir
une question d'un internaute du figaro
david qui vous demander ce que vous êtes
on parlait des gilets jaunes est ce que
vous êtes pour l'augmentation du smic
de combien nous ce que nous défendons
c'est pas seulement l'augmentation du
smic c'est une augmentation pas une
baisse des cotisations sociales une
augmentation de tous les salaires
jusqu'à 1500 euros
l'augmentation d'environ 200 euros de
tous les salaires jusqu'à 1500 euros
mais pour pas que ça pèse sur les
entreprises est pas une un allègement
des cotisations sociales
ludovic mendes vous avez entendu notre
invité ce soir critiqué fortement le
chef de l'état et puis nathalie loiseau
et la politique suivie alors une
interpellation vous avez l'honneur que
c'est pas étonnant et ça ça parait
jusque logique on parle de campagne même
au delà de la perte de copan moi je le
vis de façon quotidienne à l'assemblée
nationale qu'on soit pas d'accord c'est
presque normal selon rien ou réunis et
c'est tout à fait logique on puisse pas
être d'accord sur le fonctionnement ce
qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est
comment on peut proposer autant de
choses qui soient aussi éloignée de la
réalité
vous parlez de put alors de
l'immigration ou parler de clandestins
il faudrait faire la différence entre ce
que c'est qu'un clandestin est ce que
c'est qu'un migrant carla de façon
irrégulière et cal qui demande malgré
tout l'asile au niveau européen ce que
une fois qu'il a demandé l'asile même si
l'arrivée de façon irrégulière
il a le droit de demander l'asile donc
ce n'est pas un clandestin part entière
et ça il faudrait l'expliquer à
plusieurs reprises mais vous dites qu'il
faut protéger nos frontières le front
tient aujourd'hui c'est l'union
européenne j'ai rendu la dernière
derrière un rapport sous l'espace
schengen où je dis qu'il ya des choses
qui fonctionnent très bien
il ya des choses qui fonctionnent moins
bien mais c'est bien l'europe
aujourd'hui qui peut nous protéger
parce que la force frontex vous avez
voté contre d'ailleurs le fait que la
force mon texte puisse être améliorée et
renforcée puisse avoir des bébés un
mandat qui soit avancé et je pense que
c'est il ya que l'union européenne qui
peut y arriver
ce que tout seul dans notre coin on n'y
arrivera pas non plus et vous le savez
très bien
malgré tout fait croire aux français que
seule la france peut régler le problème
alors que la problématique et
européennes la preuve si vous parlez de
l'italie et de l'engrais assez souvent
entre monsieur ban et monsieur salvini
mais c'est grâce à monsieur hors balais
le fait qu'il eut bloqué au niveau du
conseil de l'europe le fait que la
solide et européennes la solidarité
européenne ne se met pas en place que
l'italie se retrouve dans cette
situation donc en fait
les dix à l'extrême droite fabrique
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui au niveau
européen et vous ça vous réjouissez vous
permet de dire que l'europe ne
fonctionne pas alors que un dirigeant
peut bloquer tout un système européen
sur les différents points d'abord vous
avez raison de souligner que beaucoup de
migrants qui arrivent clandestinement en
europe font ensuite une demande d'asile
parce que l'asile c'est devenu une
filiale à part entière de l'immigration
clandestine
c'est ça la réalité c'est à beaucoup
sont pas éligibles au droit d'asile
après 65 % d'entre eux vont être
dégoûtés de la base il de la demande
mais ils ne seront pas expulsés parce
qu'un rapport de la cour des comptes que
vous avez dû consulter puisque vous êtes
à parlementaire sérieux montrent qu'il
ya 94 % des déboutés du droit d'asile
qui ne sont pas expulsés sont qu'en
pratique en pratique souvent selon une
seule raison c'est ça qui est très
intéressant tient pas l'autorisation
consulaire mais c'est simple oui mais
c'est aussi parce qu'on n'a pas mis en
place l'ensemble des procédures il
conclu des accords bilatéraux avec ces
pays pour qu'ils aillent dans ce sens
parce que souvent vous avez des pays qui
reçoivent des fonds soit 10 de l'union
européenne soit directement des états et
fonds importants au titre de la
coopération etc
mais qui mais on n'a jamais conditionné
des accords migratoires enfin ces fonds
versés à une vraie maîtrise de l'afflux
migratoire et une récupération de la
ressortie sans lorsqu'ils viennent quand
l'estimant en france et en europe
ensuite un tel magot maintenant sur
frontex écoutez nous on a voté pour un
certain nombre de dispositions mais on
n'a pas voté pour un texte qui prévoyait
en réalité que frontex se substitue aux
états nous ne voulons pas que les
fonctions régaliennes des états une
divergence de fond un soin aujourd'hui
mises en oeuvre par frontex dire que
frontex doit intervenir en appui des
gouvernements nationaux
quand un pays fait face à un afflux
massif d'immigration et qu'il a besoin
de l'aide de la solidarité européenne
pour l'aider à protéger ses frontières
en pratique il a besoin d'effectifs
supplémentaires de garde côtes ou
gardes-frontières la frontex est utile
mais moi je veux pas que ce soit des
commissaires européens dans tout le
monde c'est comme monsieur avramopoulos
qu'elle commissaire aux migrations qu'il
est favorable à l'immigration aussi bien
légal peu clandestine qui aujourd'hui
client qu'est demain et la possibilité
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas de source
avait pas de preuves vous dites toujours
les gens sages sauf que vous
rassurez vous ça c'est nouveau le
fonctionnement sauf que la grèce l'a
montré et c'est frontex qui a permis à
la grèce de pouvoir s'en sortir c'est
léa zouk accompagner la grèce donc c'est
bien l'union européenne qui a aidé la
grèce à pouvoir s'en sortir dans la
gestion des flux migratoires et ce n'est
pas simplement le pays en lui même qui
était dans une crise dans une espèce de
faillite
moi je vais visiter le siège de frontex
on m'a expliqué comment ça se passait
vous avez des bateaux qui les les côtes
libyennes à 20 km des côtes qui sont
clés en main ils sont repris en main non
match le plus maintenant mais parce que
l'italie refait son travail a établi des
liens avec les limites pour quoi ça
consiste à récupérer les bateaux à
sécuriser leur travail et jusqu'en
europe et à les laisser arriver sur nos
côtes au et c'est exactement le
contraire de ce qu'il faudra viel cie
fautrel ne font pas que ça j'ai
remboursé en france principalement ça
pose le problème de l' agence qui doit
contrôler de frontières extérieure elle
doit pas aboutir à organiser
l'immigration mais avec 2.2 du fer en
son propre etc sinon justement on joue
en incitant à ce qu'ils viennent vous
les laissez moi rire vous fermez les
gars si vous arrêtez les arrivées vous
éviter que la médiane et soit un
cimetière
je suis assez d'accord sur le fait
d'éviter que la matérialité et soit un
cimetière c'est absolument une
catastrophe humaine absolument
détestable
je ne suis pas sûr que la situation de
vos amis en italie parce qu'on a un peu
l'impression que depuis que ce sont vos
amis en italie les la chose a changé en
italie je sais pas si vous êtes allé
récemment les six avaient pu voir l'état
justement des mendiants en italie est ce
que ça représente aujourd'hui toute
l'île en graciant qui a eu lieu et qui
est la situation italienne depuis que
vos amis sont au pouvoir dans ce pays
est devenu une situation qui n'était pas
connue en italie qui est une situation
nouvelle
vous avez des mendiants partout venant
de ces pays ça c'est la réalité
vos amis et donc vos ennemis n'ont pas
résolu le problème en italie traduisez a
tellement si vous permettez
c'est mon père était juste qu'elles sont
les solutions que vous allez arriver ces
élections européennes du coup par les
sujets d'actualité j'ai du mal à
comprendre vos propositions qui
permettraient à un moment de résoudre
réellement ce problème à quel moment
lorsque vous arriverez troisième
quatrième force européenne ne sais pas
à vous faire à être utile sur ce sujet
parce que vous en parlait beaucoup et
c'est un sujet qui a beaucoup agité
l'europe récemment beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui
vous pouvez en convenir je n'ai pas
compris quelle était votre solutionner
le problème n'est pas résolu
je vous donne un chiffre comme ses
passages à 15 % d'arriver en moins sur
les côtes italiennes depuis que matteo
salvini
il a d'ailleurs adopté un autre sinon
vous le savez vous m'avez dire que la
solution italienne vis-à-vis d'alibi est
la bonne vous êtes enfin moi je dis
simplement briçoise précise que l'italie
dans son histoire a toujours eu des
liens très politique un partenariat très
privilégié avec les autorités libyennes
ce qu'une voix nue est très compliqué
parce qu'on a le cas où rendu 10 pour
justement que la libye joue son rôle ce
qu'elle jouait à l'époque de kadhafi là
il faut bien le dire aussi critiquable
que ce soit kadhafi de verrous pour
éviter les flux migratoires maintenant
je vois vous avez raison sur un point
c'est que la question migratoire elle
nécessite une réponse globale c'est à la
fois bien sûr la protection des
frontières extérieures
bien sûr des contrôles et contrôle de
nos frontières nationales
parce que ça évite aussi l'été trafics
en tous genres la libre circulation des
biens et des personnes c'est aussi la
libre circulation des clandestins des
gangsters des de la drogue des armes
c'est à mais ça suffit d'aimer ce que ça
avait été résolue à ce moment là mais la
fermeté on avait nos frontières on
savait avant qu'adam assises la fermeté
n'est pas en elle-même suffisante il
faut protéger les frontières il faut
aussi un vrai partenariat ambitieux
notamment avec le continent africain
si on est capable de développer les
infrastructures routières d'électricité
télécommunications aussi c'est l'argent
du écoutez moi j'ai fait beaucoup de
déplacements en afrique aujourd'hui
c'est c'est principalement les chinois
sont en train de prendre possession des
positions très importantes
ils vont payer au sénégal d'ailleurs en
afrique on doit avoir un partenariat on
doit développer le continent africain
pour pouvoir avoir ensuite la maîtrise
des flux migratoires mais cette
politique de ferme d explicitation
mythique est juste et qui est humaine
parce que tu sais pas chez moi sont
présents là bas parce qu'ils sont pas
chères il faux semblants des fois
d'investir dans infrastructures
qui ne termine pas est d'ailleurs
désormais les pays africains font
machine arrière
parce que les chevaux font savoir qu'ils
n'ont pas levé non pas qu'ils n'ont pas
fonctionné donc vous pouvez pas dire que
c'est les chinois qui sont en train de
résoudre le problème c'est que majorés
sur les horaires les plus grands fonds
viennent de l'europe et ils sont plus
aujourd'hui fournir des états et si vous
dites que c'est les cheveux qu'ils
n'étaient pas prêts de défense et je dis
simplement qu'ils ont quitté le
continent africain à pouvoir s'émanciper
et être autorisée en profiter de
l'absence des européens pour prendre
possession d'un certain nombre de
marchés et c'est vrai vous avez raison
il mène pas du tout une politique qui
dans la dure est susceptible de
développer
vous les connaissez vous attend dès
aujourd'hui vous demander à l'union
européenne plus investir dans le
développement en afrique dans l'économie
a demandé alors ses parents ses amis ou
le développer ses actions de coopération
avec l'afrique
oui il faut je pense que la maîtrise la
défense de notre identité de notre
sécurité qui passe par la maîtrise des
frontières ça nécessite une des grande
coopération entre les pays européens
pas besoin que la commission européenne
s'en mêle on sera plus efficace en étant
quelques minutes mais vous avez oui mais
c'est envers ce n'est pas celle qu'elle
les avait tous les atouts de leur côté
et c'est depuis l'union européenne s'est
méchamment a mis un budget européen que
ça fonctionne beaucoup cette contrainte
moi mais aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que
ça fonctionne il faut des vrais
coopération n'est pas bien est à 28 on
peut passer à 5 à 8 à 10 sa dépendent
des sujets et il faut le faire à la fois
sur la maîtrise des frontières
extérieures et sur ses politiques de
coopération les deux je peux vous
reprendre sur ce point parce que j'ai
compris c'était une partie de votre
programme de faire quelque chose un
petit peu à la carte
alors je n'ai pas bien compris comment
ça marchait avec l'union monétaire ce
programme à la carte on prend un peu ce
qu'on veut dans la politique européenne
ont fait une fois une politique ensemble
une fois on a choisi de faire tout seul
j'ai pas bien compris comment ça
marchait alors je crois bien même que
vous n'avez pas bien compris vous même
parce que il y à la fois dernière aux
élections européennes votre punch line
comme on dit maintenant en mauvais
français
c'était la sortie de l'euro alors vous
avez fait une conversion idéologique
j'ai repris votre programme vous savez
je suis assez basique je lis les
rapports je lis et les déclarations et
puis je reprends et je vois que vous
avez fait un changement à 180 degrés je
vous ai écouté tout à l'heure
non dorénavant l'europe ou le savent au
fond la garde on le garde mais c'est à
dire que quand on a soi disant un corpus
idéologique que stable c'est quand même
bien je devrais d'éviter un changement à
180 degrés on aurait bien tort de mettre
de l'idéologie dans les questions
monétaires je vais vous dire il faut
être pragmatique
bien sûr que je crois qu'on avait raison
et marine le pen ait eu le courage et
plusieurs années déjà avoir de pause et
de poser la question monétaire de dire
il ya un juge herman philippot ya un
sujet il ya un sujet avec un euro dont
on voit aujourd'hui qui sait alzate à
l'allemagne au détriment des autres et
notamment de la france
maintenant la réponse on peut pas avoir
une réponse simpliste est une question
complexe donc on va pas une fois qu'on a
fait ce constat qu' on n'a pas une
monnaie qui sait à l'économie française
comment on fait pour que ce soit le cas
ou davantage le cas eh bien il ya des
marges de manoeuvre qu'on peut avoir
dans le cadre de l'euro mais ils ont
modifié la gouvernance et du club aixois
savoir politique
vous êtes rendu compte qu'il y avait une
grande part de l'électorat français
notamment mais pas le péché des plus
âgés chez les seniors qui ne voulait pas
entendre parler de la sortie de l'euro
donc vous êtes adapté aux circonstances
des électeurs on a en nous notre
objectif c'est que l'économie française
aille mieux et on fait le constat que
aujourd'hui on a eu tous les
inconvénients de l'euro et on en a pas
eu les avantages si demain on est
capable d'avoir une monnaie qu'il soit
plus un niveau plus raisonnable
laissez-moi terminer que par ailleurs on
puisse faire de la création monétaire
pas seulement aux bénéfices des banques
mais aussi au bénéfice des états et de
leurs projets au bénéfice de l'économie
de 2008 en jeu pour ajouter ce genre de
défi si un jour on arrive à ce que à
pouvoir vendre nos services en euros ou
acheter notre pétrole ou d'autres
matières premières l'euro là on aurait
réussi quelque chose
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas donc
posé la question sur l'euro et je pense
que dans tout cela porte à nolay oui
mais aujourd'hui on fait le constat
c'est que mercy le fonctionnement le
fonctionnement de la zone euro est très
mauvais l'allemagne en est le grand
bénéficiaire avec des centaines de
milliards d'euros d'excédents
commerciaux mais la plupart des autres
pays la france en tête ont un des
déficits commerciaux 13 à penser quand
surtout
sans lier sous la forme soulier qui est
lié vous savez que nous échange de parts
principal partenaire économique de la
france
exact c'est l'allemagne l'essentiel de
notre déficit se fait avec les pays
européens qui sont dans la zone euro
donc je n'ai pas bien compris quel
moment l'euro était un problème dans
notre déficit commercial est meilleur
mais mais mais je peux être d'accord
avec vous vous allez voir sur que nous
vendions enfin nos services en europe et
au cordeau là et benzema leurs illusions
qu'il faut alors qu'il faut avoir et
pour ça que vous défendre l'euro moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre justement un ministres de
la zone euro du budget qui permettrait
de permettre une économie mieux adaptées
à la zone européenne
non ce que c'était des propositions du
président macron donc je me permets de
vous poser la question et quand vous
dites que l'euro c'est on n'est pas tous
là pour partager justement le point
commun c'est plutôt inverse
l'espagne l'italie la hongrie la pologne
et autres c'est grâce à l'euro aussi
qu'ils ont pu se permettent de faire
avancer leur pays le plus rapidement
possible ah si vous regardez on prend
elle est l'ancienne monnaie espagnoles
ou portugaises ou même italienne le roi
parmi vous des choses est de la
problématique n'est pas dû à la bonne et
vous savez c'était à une économie qui
étaient à la traîne et une formation
adaptée d'ailleurs c'est l'allemagne qui
est en avance sur nous est on en train
de remonter petit à petit mais
aujourd'hui ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre ce ministre et il nommait en fait
je trouve ça très intéressant votre
question parce que la réponse des
partisans des modèles macron c'est
toujours d'aller en jeu aussi vu la
république et jette un road ne s'était
pas une insulte
elle ne le prenez pas comme tel mais la
réalité c'est que vous voulez toujours
aller plus loin dans le fédéralisme
européen
c'est à dire que vous dites si si il
faut une agence européenne de ceci il
faut une banque européenne de cela il ya
toujours voilà aller toujours plus loin
dans cette logique qui n'a pas marché
soyons lucides ce qui a fonctionné en
europe les grandes réalisations
industrielles ça et arianespace a été
abusée qui ne doivent rien la commission
européenne si la commission européenne
s'en était mêlée sur la tête
capote est lamentablement parce que ce
sont des états qui ont pris l'initiative
qui ont organisé des coopérations avec
des conglomérats industriels
on a abouti à des grands succès qui ont
permis au mans de l'europe il ya un plan
de développement pour les batteries
c'est fondamental un peu
les structures de demain bien sûr c'est
un plan qui a été lancé par la france et
par l'allemagne là vous applaudissez
invite nommer que des grandes
entreprises françaises et allemandes
je mette ensemble et peut-être avec
d'autres demain pour avoir un géant dans
tel ou tel secteur industriel
c'est une très bonne chose on a on n'a
jamais critiqué ce genre d'initiative
mais vous voyez bien d'ailleurs que ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'on salue l'initiative elle
passait généralement totalement alors
des institutions européennes donc on a
des institutions européennes la
commission européenne est censée plein
d'appels à projets qui ont fonctionné ce
marché transfrontalier je peux montrer
plein d'entreprises qui fonctionne entre
le france et luxembourg la france et
l'allemagne la france et la belgique
pareil avec les régulateurs émanation de
l'union européenne en partie plaisante
ces deux ministres qu'on va pulser l'adn
d'habiter à la proposition qui a été
faite par jean claude juncker à une
époque sur la création justement même du
grand numéro 2 français s'est interrogé
par plusieurs gouvernements juncker
fasse des propositions que des grands
pays comme la france l'allemagne
on est tous sont capables de prendre des
initiatives sans à un commissaire
européen qui la donnent des consignes
enfin c'est pas des coups qu'elle vidéo
présente les cas vous avez de notre pays
pour penser qu'on aurait besoin d'avoir
la tutelle et l'otan il est cher le thé
sa voile il faut sortir c'est justement
est ce que vous êtes pour un couple
franco allemand fort
non moi je crois que c'est très limité
comme ambition est très méprisant aussi
à l'égard des autres parce que j'ai vu
que madame macron s'était engagé là
dedans avec le persil avec le traité
d'oslo chapelle qui était à quelques
était tout sauf un succès est évidemment
non je crois que l'allemagne est un pays
voisin est un pays ami
on peut avoir des intérêts convergents
on peut aussi avoir parfois être parfois
compétiteur c'est normal et c'est pas
grave et on ya aussi beaucoup d'autres
pays en europe avec lesquels on doit
avoir les partenariats seraient dus à
réduire ference vous savez large entre
nous on ne met d'accord avec eux le
monde n'a jamais été aussi forte
lorsqu'il y avait un grand calme en fort
aujourd'hui être tout seul la france
force était seul en europe
c'est en vérité une france faible on l'a
aujourd'hui avec mêmes bakang mettre
d'accord là dessus nos médias ça c'est
très méprisant pour les grands pays
comme l'espagne comme l'italie qui sont
nos voisins dans d'autres pays qui a
est aujourd'hui ont pris un poids
important il faut pas se réduire à ce
couple franco allemand
vous savez il ya un côté un peu
restrictif ça fait 40 ans qu'on vend ça
aux français et ce couple
franco-allemand ça consistait à sallèles
un telle manne ceux de la france sur à
peu près tous les sujets donc ne nous
enfermons pas là dedans
et soyons capables d vraie coopération
avec des pays en niant bilatérales
parfois en multilatérale mais sortons de
ce modèle lourd contraignant coercitif
que cette europe où tout se décide à 28
août où s'impose aux 28 et souvent
créances
c'est inefficace impôts de l'impuissance
aidé beaucoup de frustration moi j'ai
juste une question est ce que vous
pensez pas que l'allemagne a pu s'en
sortir parce que les politiques ont su
même quand ce n'était pas du même bord
travailler ensemble alors que la phrase
on me suis fait non il ne serait pas
majoritaire alors ne dites pas ça c'est
pas exactement ce que c'est parce que
tout ce que je veux dire parce que c'est
parce que je veux dire jusqu'il ya des
moments où dans nos collectivités
locales qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
d'accord on est dans l'obligation de
s'entendre pour avancer parfois
l'assemblée nationale c'est un peu
différent chacun l'opposition joue le
défi l'opposition stérile
par exemple la commission sur la
politique allemande a pas été plus
vertueuse dans le sens là parce qu'ils
ont su se mettre autour d'une table et
discuter sous forme de consensus alors
que les français ont boudé faisait
parfois ce qui était fait par les autobu
précise c'est peut-être la raison et et
des politiques
et là je pense qu'on a l'un comme
l'autre autour de cette table si on
l'est là aussi qu'on représente une
france un peu en colère une france qui
voulait autre chose c'est aussi à cause
de ça maintenant on sera jamais d'accord
et ça je pense que vous vous comment on
est totalement en phase sur le sujet
est-ce que c'est pas juste une
responsabilité politique et pas
simplement le fait que ce soit
l'allemagne parce que pendant longtemps
on a aussi pu écouter madame le pen a
dit que c'était aussi la faute de berlin
où berlin nous imposer son diktat
alors que berlin n'impose rien comme
bruxelles n'impose rien et c'était pas
pour être généré la sécurité de hollande
hier on apprend aujourd'hui et comment
il va le dire mais vous avez posé une
question très intéressante pourquoi dans
les 27 autres pays de l'union en baisse
26 si on considère que les britanniques
sont partis il ya des mods il ya partout
des coalitions gouvernementales alors
différents parlers l'ombre et d'ailleurs
des traditions et saufs oui parce que le
fidesz arrive avec 50% des voix mais
sinon la plupart des pays européens
c'est des coalitions gouvernementales
pourquoi parce que vous avez des modes
de scrutin à la proportionnelle qui
oblige à des compromis et des
concessionnaires varinard semble enfin
nous venons mais ils ont des modes
d'approché intégral partout nous macron
propose une dose homéopathique de
proportionnelle sanaag leur a rien ça va
continuer à l'exercice sectaire du
pouvoir c'est l'exercice secteur du
pouvoir qui fait qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez la croix une majorité de 300
députés
ma chronique qui votent comme un seul
homme et loi qui propose beaucoup plus
d'avoir rien à l'état de l'opinion
assez du coup ça permet un exercice
totalement secteur du pouvoir ça empêche
les compromis et les consensus qui sont
souvent bénéfique cessé mais moi je suis
pas en europe c'est jupiter par minerve
ça sera le mot de la fin messieurs merci
beaucoup c'est bien mais c'est d'avoir
participé aux auditions publiques tout
de suite la suite avec nos deux
consoeurs qui font leur entrée sur le
plateau
brigitte boucher oriane mancini bonsoir
mesdames
une interpellation est une question d'un
internaute du figaro pour vous nicolas
bay qui s'appelle babineau il dit
apparemment jordan bardella votre tête
de liste plutôt bonne impression durant
sa campagne
et en cette campagne votre contact c'est
ce qu'il ignore pourquoi marine le pen
s'obstine à vouloir rester leader de
votre parti alors que je suis remettra
jamais de son débat raté face à emmanuel
macron chacun ses missions marine le pen
est la présidente du rassemblement
national est au second tour de la
présidentielle elle a rassemblé 11
millions de suffrages et son débat
aujourd'hui
non mais d'accord elle l'a reconnu
elle-même avec humilité je crois que
beaucoup de français ont aujourd'hui
totalement oublié un débat télé peut
être important mais ça n'était jamais
qu'un débat télé il ya maintenant deux
ans il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
depuis deux ans jordan bardella et notre
tête de liste on a fait le choix un
choix audacieux d'ailleurs c'est celui
de la jeunesse pour porter un projet
d'avenir qu'est ce projet d'europe des
nations et il fait il mène excellemment
cette campagne nous sommes une équipe je
reviens sur la ses côtés et c'est sur
marine le pen toujours leader mais là
l'internaute dit qu'il ya quand même
moins d'un français sur cinq qui jugent
qu'elle ferait une bonne présidente vous
avez les sondages ça va ça vient la
réalité c'est que notre mouvement
la cote de popularité de marine le pen
et les intentions de vote pour le
rassemblement national sont plutôt au
beau fixe et suscite plutôt l'envié la
jalousie de nos concurrents
donc on se repose pas sur nos lauriers
on est mobilisé en campagne on dit aux
français que c'est important d'aller
voter parce que les enjeux de deux
européennes sont absolument fondamentaux
pour le pays
mais honnêtement on a la chance que peu
de formations politiques ont d'avoir à
la fois un leader
à une présidente qui voilà qui n'est pas
contesté dans sa famille politique et
d'avoir une liste est en ordre de
bataille de voir maintenant des mois et
qui est en tête dans la plupart des
intensités
alors j'ai quand même un peu contesté et
on va en parler maintenant chez certains
de vos alliés potentiels 1 les partis
populistes nationalistes certains
trouvent que marine le pen n'est pas
forcément si fréquentable que cela mais
on va en parler
dans cette dernière partie de l'émission
puisque on va maintenant se projeter
dans l'après 26 mai et ses organes qui
pose la première question puisque marine
le pen était à bruxelles pour soutenir
vos allées belge du vlaams belang
votre objectif c'est de former une
alliance européenne des nations mais
avec qui vous savez aujourd'hui on a
déjà une alliance européenne des nations
on a déjà huit nationalités 40 députés
dans le la futur mandature au lendemain
du 26 mai on sera en situation de faire
un très grand groupe beaucoup plus large
il ya il reste une ou deux inconnus
j'anticipe peut-être les deux nos
questions oui la pologne ou la hongrie
mais la plupart des autres sont déjà
acquis les seuls groupes populistes en
europe mais aussi les polonais veulent
absolument faire un groupe distinct et
bien c'est leur droit
nicolas dupont aignan et dans un autre
justement avec les colonies l'union pour
la nulle part il est à moins de 5% dans
les sondages et donc il y aura peut-être
pas d'élu donc elle ne nous projetons
pas quand même trop rapidement mais le
cueillait certains qui veulent faire un
groupe séparé ça empêchera pas de se
mettre d'accord sur un certain nombre de
votes 1 de voter ensemble c'est pas
c'est pas incompatibles et c'est déjà
pas le cas aujourd'hui mais on a
beaucoup d'alliés qui sont déjà acquis
matteo salvini a fait une conférence de
presse au nom de notre groupe une aile
il ya quelques semaines il avait à ses
côtés des allemands de l'est faisaient
les vrais finlandais
le parti du peuple danois ces deux
formations politiques qui sont en pleine
croissance qui auront de nombreux
députés
je pense que nous aurons avec nous
également les espagnols de vox nous
étions avec marine le pen à prague ya
quelques jours avec nos alliés tchèques
slovaques bulgares dont nous allons
avoir une coalition qui aura au moins
une quinzaine de nationalités
différentes
le poids sans doute au 112 90 ou 100
députés et peut-être en effet que nous
parviendrons pas forcément lendemain du
26 mai peut-être que ça prendra quelques
mois deux fois de travailler pub
avec les polonais du parti droit et
justice avec pourquoi pas les endroits
du fides j'ai vu aujourd'hui même avec
ça on arrive on réussira à combler un
grand groupe qui sera déjà l'une des
principale force du parlement européen
c'est possible et cette troisième et on
sera peut-être encore plus important si
dans un second temps on parvient à
travailler avec les polonais ou les
hongrois j'ai vu que viktor orban a
annoncé aujourd'hui même qu'ils ne
soutiendraient pas comme speed lundi
derrière comme candidat la commission
européenne manfred weber qui est le
leader du ppe donc tout ça montre qu'il
ya une tectonique
c'était mon payen d'accord avec viktor
orban matteo salvini marine le pen ou
par evans matteo salvini et là les gars
sont déjà dans notre groupe donc non
c'est ce que je vous dis depuis tout à
l'heure une quinzaine et s'il vous plaît
on a une quinzaine de nationalités qui
sont déjà acquises et il reste
principalement deux inconnus ce sont les
polonais les hongrois est ce qu'on
arrivera à travailler avec eux dès le
lendemain du 26 mai peut-être mais c'est
pas sûr est ce qu'on y arrivera dans les
mois qui suivront ça me paraît tout à
fait envisageable parce que je ne vois
pas victor rabanne qui défend une
position très claire pour plus de
souveraineté nationale pour moins de
pouvoirs à la commission européenne pour
plus de fermeté sur l'immigration resté
au ppe qui incarne exactement le
contraire alors de ce projet tête de
liste de son parti aux élections
européennes donné une interview dans le
figaro il ya quelques jours il disait
j'espère que nous resterons au sein du
ppe
c'est notre intérêt et celui de l'europe
c'est quand même mal parti une alliance
avec ouvrages et surtout un débat à
l'intérieur du fidesz de viktor orban
donc je vous invite faire votre travail
aurélie ce type pour étudier les
rapports de force
mais aujourd'hui que victor ben
aujourd'hui même a dit clairement qu'ils
ne soutiendraient pas le candidat du pp
à tête de la commission européenne un
débat au sein du 13 mai mettant au ban
parce que c'est un personnage mais
controversé mais ça montre sur raison
des atteintes à l'état de droit dans son
pays lancée mais aussi on peut toujours
dire qu'il est un tas doit encore
faut-il le prouver
j'ai eu l'occasion de me rendre aussi
bien à budapest varsovie et j'ai pu
constater que les accusations
d'atteintes à l'état de droit était pas
du tout fondées mais ils sont en
revanche présents sur la justice
je suis désolé mais je pense pas qu'ils
- liberté de presse il la presse a en
pollen qu'en france aujourd'hui on alors
sur place
vous pouvez nous apporter un démenti
j'ai pu constater et les échanges que
j'ai eus aussi bien avec des ministres
qu'avec des députés qu'avec des
associations y compris très hostiles au
gouvernement en place ont permis d'avoir
ma propre opinion oui et je pense que
c'est atteinte à l'état de droit sont
des prétextes de l'union européenne qui
en veut énormément
la commission européenne a eu énormément
viktor orban d'avoir refusé les quotas
obligatoires de migrants et depuis lui
cherche des poux dans la tête mais ce
que vous dites est très intéressant sur
le ppe à ce qu'on nous dit toujours est
ce que vous allez réussir à faire une
coalition des gens à qui vous n'êtes pas
forcément d'accord sur tout
nous on est souverainiste et ça ne pose
pas de problème d'avoir aussi des points
de divergence
il ya des spécificités nationales qu'il
faut respecter mais ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il ne dise pas été
considérables à l'intérieur du ppe ou à
l'intérieur du groupe des socialistes
infiniment plus important chez vous
paraît infiniment plus importantes que
celles subies nicolas ii vous avez dit
pourquoi pas une alliance avec boxe boxe
ils sont xénophobes
ils sont misogynes son anti anti
féministe anti avortement ils le disent
ouvertement ça vous pose pas de problème
vous savez moi mais vous porter des
accusations
moi je connais bien aveugle je connais
très bien santiago abbas calquella
leader ils ne sont pas du tout xénophobe
ils ne sont pas du tout anti féministes
qui défendent des positions qui sont
très voisines des notes sur la question
de l'immigration
ils sont pour les libertés économiques
nous n'avons pas de divergences majeures
vous il faut quand même avoir conscience
que vous portez là des accusations qui
sont extrêmement grave extrêmement
insultant
est ce que vous êtes capable de les
étayer les arguments tc ouvertement
non mesdames altum en 10 parties par vol
requis par boxer qui ce qu'ils disent
anti-avortement puisqu'il son nom il dit
simplement ils sont pour la natalité
pour le soutien aux familles c'est pas
la même chose
ils disent qu'il faut la fermeté
migratoires ils veulent défendre l'unité
nationale face aux velléités
d'indépendance la catalogne
sur tous ces sujets là on a des armes
convergence de vues il peut y avoir des
différences
vous savez entre les pays européens il
ya des traditions politiques différentes
et des histoires différentes
il ya des situation géographique et
géopolitique différentes qui font
d'ailleurs qu'au parlement européen où
parler des votes tout à l'heure il n'ya
pas toujours d une point de clivage
entre la droite et la gauche et les
clivages entre souvent la grotte à
gauche votent ensemble
il ya des clivages entre l'est et
l'ouest entre le nord et le sud et c'est
normal cela montre aussi ça montre aussi
que l'europe ça peut pas être ni un
super état ni un supermarché avec voit
que ce n'est pas tout n'est pas uniforme
is able si je puis dire en europe avec
le succès électoral de boxe le retour du
franquisme en espagne mais qui a fondé
le parti populaire qu'est le parti
espagnol qui au moment au sein du ppe
c'est un ministre de franco
voilà alors que santiago abascal il a un
peu plus de 40 ans il n'y a pas connu
cette période il a créé un nouveau parti
qui n'a absolument rien à voir et qui ne
ne se lavait faire nullement au
franquisme
donc s'il ya du franquisme en espagne eh
bien ça vient de ceux qui ont fondé le
parti allié de monsieur wauquiez c'est à
lui qu'il faut poser la question au
parti polonais par exemple le pis là il
ya dit marine le pen est trop proche de
la russie
marine le pen est trop protectionniste
et puis il ya aussi l'héritage de jean
marie le pen est ce que la
dédiabolisation qui a eu lieu en france
sur marine le pen elle n'a pas
fonctionné à l'échelle en général que la
pologne pour des raisons historiques que
tout le monde comprend et la défiance ou
de la méfiance très vives à l'égard de
la russie
c'est parfaitement compréhensible nous
on n'a jamais voulu s'inféoder de
quelque manière que ce soit à la russie
on est choisi il faut une position
équilibrée
l'union européenne fait la guerre froide
elle a réussi on s'est engagé dans une
politique de sanctions contre la russie
dont nous sommes les premières victimes
parce que le la réponse de la russie à
ces sanctions économiques ça a été un
embargo certain nombre de produits
notamment agricoles et c'est ce qui
pénalise lourdement nos agriculteurs en
france est d'une humeur générale en
europe
sortons de cette logique là la russie
défend ses intérêts c'est normal
défendons les noms l'annexion d'un crime
et il ya fayyad et des résultats oui il
prend pourquoi vous mettez des prêts
spanyi enfin il ya un paradoxe quand
même c'est que l'union européenne
voudrait qu'on reconnaisse
l'indépendance du kosovo
mais par contre considère que l'annexion
de la primaire est un casus belli je
rappelle quand même que la crimée était
en russie il ya 70 ans et que c'est un
cadeau de
de nikita khrouchtchev à l'ukraine donc
est il par référendum à 96% ils ont fait
le choix d'intégrer la fédération
d'origine donc la situation sociale
depuis quand même reconnu les frontières
et on peut pas 5 apparaît comme sa
version à bien on applique le même
raisonnement pour le kosovo oui bien sûr
voilà à l'union européenne c'est
exactement le contraire
on conviendra qu'il ya quand même un
paradoxe on va parler de votre allié
italien matteo salvini est ce qui n'est
pas en train de prendre le leadership
des droites européennes et de
marginaliser marine le pen et vous avez
vous travaillé ensemble bien sûr qu'il
est la figure de proue de notre famille
politique à l'échelle continentale
la lega aura un très grand nombre de
députés européens le 26 mai au soir
il est premier ministre et ministre de
l'italie aujourd'hui donc évidemment il
a un rôle moteur dans notre alliance
notre coalition européenne
nous travaillons ensemble dans le même
groupe depuis des années on a un lien
très fort et demain nous aurons les
français les italiens au sein de notre
groupe qui seront les sans doute les
deux plus fortes délégations
il n'y a pas de vague ardres et la
coprésidente du groupe au couteau on
verra comment on s'organise c'est pas il
y aura évidemment il faudra donner de la
place à chacun mais la délégation
française le rassemblement national au
sein du futur groupe aura gardera un
rôle important une place importante mais
ya pas de querelles d'ego entre marine
le pen et matteo salvini répartition des
rôles
on va tous dans la même direction on
veut construire cette petite
gouvernement finalement bien sûr que si
on connaît pas été encore au
gouvernement
c'était lequel les guerres il ya pas si
longtemps et vous savez qu'il ya pas
voilà il ya l'autriche et l'italie qui
sont au pouvoir et puis il ya vous à
côté quoi vous avez dans notre future
coalition il ya une quinzaine de
nationalités y en a pour l'instant trois
qui sont responsabilités
gouvernementales
la lega en italie le fpe en autriche et
le parti est créée en estonie et les
autres sont dans l'opposition mais ceux
qui sont en opposition aux vocations
arrivée aux responsabilités dans les
intervenants deuxième division du voilà
mais non c'est pas ça c'est simplement
que les situations sont pas les mêmes
c'est matteo salvini il a obtenu 17% des
voix aux législatives et par le jeu des
coalitions il s'est retrouvé vide par
ministre de l'italie et c'est une
excellente nouvelle
nous on a un mode de scrutin majoritaire
dont on parlait tout à l'heure qui est
très anti démocratique et qui fait que
marine le pen avec 30 5% 34% des voix au
second tour de la présidentielle
elle n'a obtenu que six députés sur 577
à l'assemblée vous conviendrait qu on
n'est pas un modèle de démocratie et
qu'on ferait bien de pas trop donner de
leçons de démocratie d'état de droit aux
pays de l'est
c'est le jeu des législatives on a envie
de vous dire juste matteo salvini a
prononcé un discours à fort lee sur le
balcon ou mussolini avait assisté dans
les années 20 un massacre de partisans
de la démocratie qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé
écoutez matteo salvini se déplace en
italie partout où il va dans les lieux
publics
vous savez si on compte qu'en garde
pouvait sans doute qu'emmanuel macro
edouard philippe conduit à passer outre
les discours ou à des endroits où il ya
eu des chefs d'état français quand on
traite contre la russie mais évidemment
quand émotions on est allé je vous
rappelle qu'il y avait ces jeunes
partisans effectivement accroché pendus
aux réverbères natoire mais c'est
complexe et les polémiques dérisoires
c'est pas parce que c'est le symbole
pourquoi c'est parce qu'il a vu
apparaître problème il va partout en
italie il ya du recyclage des discours
sur des balcons ou des leaders
communistes dans le passé en q2 discours
si on commence à interdire de tous les
lieux où il ya des personnalités
controversées ou très critiquable ont
mené des actions des discours et on
pourra plus aller nulle part
tout ça c'est des polémiques dérisoires
c'est de la petite politique
politicienne ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
on a beaucoup qui sont très agacés du
succès de matteo salvini les bons
résultats qu'il obtient comme nice de
l'intérieur les bons sondages pour la
lega aux élections européennes mais
qu'il faut un puck toulois les hasards
qui tient pas là une référence
clin d'oeil bien sûr que non mais
pourquoi on passé pour que sa vie serait
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
interprète forcément voir oui mais il
faut pas interpréter créé tellement
c'est tellement évident nicolas bay non
je crois que c'est pas du tout mauvais
pas le voir bon pascal canfin était
notre invité la semaine dernière le
numéro deux sur la liste renaissance et
l'écologiste évidemment et on l'a
interrogé sur votre positionnement
puisque vous avez pris des positions
écologistes sous le thème du localisme 1
et or pascal canfin nous disait mais
quelle est la crédibilité du
rassemblement national qui soutient sur
la planète poutine l'homme de gazprom
trump qui relance la prospection
pétrolière ou encore bo le scénario au
brésil qui rase la forêt tropicale voilà
c'était l'argument de pascal canfin pour
mettre en cause cet engagement que les
séparations gratuitement parce que là
donc il faut faire les gars poutine il
faut faire la guerre à tron donc non
seulement macron isolés sur la scène
européenne il veut faire la guerre à
toutes les grandes puissances dans le
monde
tout ça est quand même pas très sérieux
et moi ce que je note bon honnêtement
les maquereaux nice qui donne des leçons
l'écologie après ce qu'a dit nicolas
hulot quand il a quitté le gouvernement
moi ça me fait un peu sourire qu'est ce
que nous défendons nous défendons
simplement un modèle économique qui est
écologique et qui respecte
l'environnement
aujourd'hui vous avez ceux qui parlent
d'écologie qui a la foi font de
l'écologie punitive le culpabiliser les
français qui utilisent la voiture pour
aller travailler ou pour rechercher du
travail mais et défendre un modèle
économique qui consiste à fabriquer en
asie de produits manufacturés qui sont
vendus en europe des matières sont
ensuite retraité et sur un autre
continent par exemple en afrique
tout ça c'est le modèle anti écologique
avoir pas tout en france maintenant mais
on pourra essayer de produire tout ce
qu'on peut produire est fabriqué en
france en europe devrait produits
fabriqués en france en europe et on
devrait avoir recours aux exploits aux
importations pardon uniquement lorsque
ces des produits qu'on n'est pas en
situation et en italie ce carbone aux
frontières
mais en fait si on peut pas avoir des
produits qui respectent aucune dans la
fabrication aucune de nos normes
sociales aucune aucune de nos normes
sanitaires
aucune demeure environnementale
concrètement c'est quoi c'est un gamin
qui travaillent 15 heures par jour payé
au lance-pierre avec dans des usines qui
polluent toute la planète voilà eh bien
il faut que le produit qui est fabriqué
dans ces conditions là quand ils
arrivent en europe et des barrières
douanières
voilà alors ça ne profite en opposition
à ce qu'insinuent ont partagé
mais beaucoup de gens lui dire oui
d'accord minorité kazim est alors qu'ils
votent l'état tu es libre échange au
parlement européen sont les amis ce sont
les républicains sont des amis de
monsieur m'a trouble le téléphone
n'étiez pas dans l'hémicycle au moment
de voter ont toujours voté contre 7e
alain les accords de libre échange n'est
pas débutée
tafta ya jamais eu de vote il y avait un
vote n'y avait pas de député toujours il
peut y en avoir un qui absorbe une autre
nom mais a toujours plusieurs qu'ils
sont là pour voter on a toujours été
récemment on a toujours voté constamment
concerne tous les traités de libre
échange
je pense que vous faites allusion c'est
à dire puisque le taffetas vous savez
que finalement il n'a pas été assez
d'accord c'est le traité de libre
échange avec les états unis qui est en
cours de préparation dans l'opacité la
plus totale
la commission européenne fait sa
tambouille dans son coin le parlement
européen étaient tenus à l'écart
et c'est donald trump qui ai mis un coup
d'arrêt à cet accord de libre-échange
donc en revanche ce qui a été voté par
le parlement européen
et j'ai voté contre s'étale l'accord de
libre-échange avec le canada
voilà et mais nous sommes contre le
principe qui consiste à voir des
produits facturés à fabriquer le bout du
monde qui arrive sans barrières
douanières en france en ne respectant
pas nos normes parce que c'est ce mode
honnêtement 50000 super tankers qui
sillonnent la planète chaque super
tankers pollue autant que des millions
de véhicules individuels
ça c'est le modèle authentiquement
entier écologique il faut combattre
l'écologie un million un million
d'espèces menacées de disparition à
c'est ce que dit le rapport de l'onu
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire selon vous
pour éviter l' iphone elle est très
complexe mais je pense que c'est tout un
système économique vertueux qui fois
restaurée et qui passent en effet par
les circuits courts produire consommer
quand même retraités ce district
au rassemblement national en est ce que
c'est pas de l'opportunisme politique
vous surfez sur la vague du moment
plutôt que de production pensais que mon
boulot quand même le meilleur temps vous
disent aussi prêts c'est normal
puisqu'ils sont contre tous les
mouvements on le voit sur la surface de
la planète s'allier salaires amène à la
lutte contre l'immigration
non mais honnêtement c'est quand même un
peu simpliste et vous conviendrait quand
même que notre jour et on a toujours été
contre les accords de libre échange et
contre ce modèle économique l'heure et
est aujourd'hui on souligne avec
d'autant plus d'ardeur que en défendant
un modèle alternatif on a une vision
très écologique peut être qu'on le
disait - on l'exprimé moins sous cette
forme là mais vous conviendrez quand
même qu'on n'a pas changé d'opinion et
ceux qui nous parlent d'écologie toute
la journée c'est quand même aussi ceux
qui on veut qu'ils ont qui défendent ce
modèle du libre échange mondialisé
merci beaucoup nicolas bleus après celle
avec nous aujourd'hui la semaine
prochaine mais on parlera d'éconologis
notamment puisque yannick jadot sera
notre invité mais pas à seulement lui
puisqu'il y aurait également dans la
même émission
raphaël glucksmann et ian brossât a mais
attention hein si je parle de la gauche
émiettée chacun interviendra pour sa
part séparément chacun 20 minutes la
semaine prochaine donc rendez vous pour
un nouveau rendez-vous d'auditions
publiques très bonne soirée à tous et à
bientôt